jean louis borloo à la tête de l'union
des démocrates et indépendants l invité
de preuves par 3 bonsoir je suis non
merci d'être avec nous bienvenue dans le
studio de public sénat en partenariat
avec l' agence france-presse
et puis l'application tivi tchèque
d'orange qui permet aux téléspectateurs
de réagir et de poser directement leurs
questions durant cette émission tout à
l'heure kerr requis qui est dit de l'
agence france-presse
puis perrine tarneaud de public sénat
nous rejoindront pour vous interroger
sur eux bien sûr les ambitions bien sûr
de votre force centriste et puis sur les
votre propre jean louis borloo on pense
à 2014 les municipales tient à paris et
puis 2017 la présidentielle on va
d'abord évoqué ensemble si vous le
voulez bien y est t'as qu'à vous êtes à
camaret c'est la réalité gevrier
politique des années qui viennent et
vous l'avez en tête comme moi on évoque
d'abord les difficultés du gouvernement
dont vous avez dénoncé l'amateurisme
jean marc ayrault vient de procéder à un
recadrage général est ce que vous allez
donc cesser de céder à ce qu'edouard
balladur a appelle la mode anti héros il
n'y a pas de bonnes en pierrot
nous avons un chef de gouvernement le
pauvre qui est prisonnier d'une
impréparation incroyable de l'alternance
enfin moi honnêtement je pensais qu'il
était très qui savent exactement qu'ils
avaient une vision sociale la
compétitivité la désastreuse désastre
iain les allusions au nom du pays je
suis donné que je suis assez stupéfait
en réalité la préparation c'était de
d'affiner l'antisarkozysme ça s'est
résumé à peu près ça l'ump n'ayant fait
aujourd'hui non tu es un bon compte
donc la question c'est le cap
franchement prenez cet exemple assez
simple on peut prendre 3 4 l'europe
voilà il ya un traité fait pas croire
qu'on va renégocier tout seul un traité
à 27 c gros tasil utile ou tard non mais
c'est quand même très embêtant que ce
soit le chef du gouvernement qui est en
face qui raconte qu' il ya un espèce de
pâte de croissance qui existe nulle part
c'est juste voilà ça s'assume
les chefs du hum d'autoriser justement
ça prenne de leadership et de vision
après on a un texte sur le logement qui
est ni fait ni à faire on dit en gros
que ce soit les communes qui
consommeront sociales elles ont pas
l'argent cepal c'est pendant leurs
compétences c'est aux bailleurs sociaux
de construire ou à l'état enfin c'est
pas on nous pu ensuite un texte sur le
gouvernement point fr neuf cents
terrains de l'état vente la grande
mesure ils sont tous déjà vendu ou
quasiment enfin précision oui dans mes 2
4 pression de sago dit on au gré des
unes de la presse je m'accroche et
fictivité on est dans une situation
qu'aucun gouvernement n'ait jamais
connue oui ce serait faux vrais
totalement faux enfin tous les
gouvernements sont toujours dans cette
situation là
la compétitivité tout d'un coup ils
découvrent qu'ils apprennent le coût du
travail entre l'expliquent le président
via la télévision le prisme inc on voit
que monsieur gallois va faire un rapport
on connaît tous les conclusions il faut
évidemment d'augmenter la tva pour taxer
les importations est un petit peu de csg
est simple on le connaîtra plus durable
mais sauf que ils ont noué nous ont dit
qu'ils avaient pris enfin conscience de
ça ils planquent le rapport aux gallois
en réalité c'est ça ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en ont mais on sait ce qu'il
ya dedans on la connaîtra rien on
connaît exactement est un très bon voilà
et rideaux la tvr mais tout le monde le
sait non il est enterré avant même
d'être là on va prendre la partie qui va
être la partie des phrases à les
filières les crédits impôts recherche
d'innovation va enfin alors qu'on sait
qu'on a un problème de coût du travail
majeurs penser que la france c'est sur
la fiche de paye qui a financé la
formation le logement la politique
familiale solidarité va c'est un vrai
sens raconte c'est bon ça vous le saviez
ok oui mais qu'est ce qui se faisait en
juillet on décide d'annuler la tva qui
touche les importations pour augmenter
les charges des entreprises on a trois
millions de chômage dans les tri yann
sommer et donc on a un problème de
câbles général hors du coup savez
l'autorité c'est c'est le leadership qui
emmène sur un cap c'est pas juste ap de
cette histoire de de vincent peillon
moi je ne demande pas sa démission
facettes a d'abord c'est à sa conscience
de savoir ce qu'il a à faire et si la
s'excuser c'est pas auprès du produit
c'est auprès de tous ceux qui sont
toujours confrontées ça les parents qui
savent pas comment prendre ce problème
c'est les éducateurs spécialisés mais si
ce n'est pas inutile gère le sol
réalisation si on n'est pas dans la
société qu'ils ont ce n'importe quoi
n'importe quand n'importe comment dans
n'importe quel statut poinçon me lisent
les questions et les chargés d'éduquer
d'apprendre à lire à écrire à nos
enfants un croyez moi il est assez de
boulot et donc tout ça
un dépend du fait que le président avait
tranché l'alternance ça sert un peu à ça
voilà on a pas mais c'est lui avec sa
conscience et pas l'opposition de
demander la démission seront suivis
comme ça tu accordes ébéniste enfin vos
amis monsieur lagarde centriste oui
puisque lui il est par exemple pour
l'expérimentation des coffee shops et il
salue le courage de vincent peillon qui
a osé ouvert leur ouvrir le débat
je laisse pas sur la même ligne que
votre ami non mais attendez on percute
et maire de drancy tno mais essayez pas
j'ai pas vous êtes toujours très très
mignon c'est d'azur dont on a débattu
dans ma ville il ya très très longtemps
qu'on a mis des systèmes de récupération
de seringue voilà piloté par lilian non
un grenat des organismes non mais
attendez
non mais d'une manière générale on a
tous évidemment des mains tendues
expérimental intelligente évidemment moi
j'ai mis en place des tunnels et ducati
pour les gamins je vous garantis que
vous rendez vous faites ça et vous
sentez de là si vous avez encore envie
c'est que vous êtes un peu un peu space
vrai donc il faut évidemment pas avoir
une politique ce qui est simplement il
ya ceux qui sont au front de la drogue
et c'est à eux que le ministre a plutôt
des excuses le poème de quoi
gouvernementale
est ce que vous êtes inquiet à l'idée
qu'il faudrait envisager des élections
anticipées certains l'évoquent
non mais on peut penser que le premier c
on a le sentiment finalement qu'un
président en a plus a plus grand chose à
dire sur les cas parce que si même il
abandonne la la compétitivité
l'industrialisation du pays où sa ré
industrialisation je vois pas très bien
quelle est sa mission sans câble donc
finalement peut-être se dit il que ça
serait plus commode de ne pas avoir à
gérer la majorité mais sans mouvement
l'elysée mais ça lui appartient c'est le
seul décideur de situation est ce que
certains s'en sortent mieux que d'autres
au sein du gouvernement je n'ai pas à
donner des
les mauves et non mais je vous donne des
noms de manuel valls
mais je vais vous dire le drian a
apparemment bien son boulot à l'aller ou
non mais il le sait tous un bon
donnerait un fait bien son boulot valls
et bien son boulot intérieur enfin que
je sache c'est pas parce qu'il est à la
mode avec qui fait bien son boulot
vincent peillon était à la mode hier il
y avait à dire des articles est présenté
comme un successeur possible déjà de
jean marc ayrault comme quoi il faut
vraiment ne vous écriviez tous les jours
vous parler tous les jours c'est votre
boulot mais non mais je ressens parce
que evry parce que voilà il ya une
espèce de vérité de difficultés de
tellin qui fait que de même que le drian
joue à bien se préparer parce que la
marine nationale et donc l'ensemble de
la défense un sujet qui me passionne
qu'il est il ya d arsenal dans son dans
sa région mena mais sinon c'est le reste
je dois dire que c'est un peu c'est
j'attends wallon doit d'accord et à
propos du premier ministre
il ya effectivement beaucoup de
critiques qui pleuvent sur lui y compris
dans son camp d'ailleurs edouard
balladur a rappelé que c'était un homme
respectable
évidemment qu'il est respectable me
tournait à me manquerait plus que le
chef du gouvernement soit considéré
comme quelqu'un de pas respectable
d'abord il est lui-même il l'est pas sa
fonction il n'est pas à l'abri des
critiques c'est une autre question
ce qui me paraît le plus embêtant très
franchement c'est pas tout ce qu'on dit
l'autorité le cas est ce parce que deux
ans de manière c'est la prime à ceux qui
font des couacs
c'est lui qui appelle en mai donc c'est
pas c'est pas bien ça alors c'est vrai
nom c'est que l'ennui pousser mais ces
deux là le cap et la préparation pré
vrai que le cap leucate je sais pas
prêts à gouverner à gauche
l'ensemble l'ensemble puis on voit bien
d'ailleurs c'est et en plus ce cartel
cercap vous avez les membres du
gouvernement sans soutien et vous avez
les autres qui soutiennent son
participer au gouvernement
c'est quand même un truc assez étrange
je parle du front de gauche qui soutient
soldes anticipés aller vers allah il
participait également embauché soutient
vraiment il se revendique car il
participe à moins que ça et un ps qui
est complètement fracturé sur les
principaux sujets entre ceux qui sont
encore à confondre les riches
et les entreprises la cible est au fond
quelle est la faute majeure en ce moment
là qu'est ce qui dans 10 ans restera un
gouvernement qui n'a pas compris que la
facilité qui consiste à dénoncer
d'entrepreneurs ou le capitalisme
familial dans des crises industrielles
ça c'est une faute de ça mais moi je
viens d'une région qui avait 26 % ce qui
nous a sauvés
les japonais toyota rens pensez que je
savais combien gagne par exemple
atteindre bon foot est complètement
mercedes président mercedes et gagne
bien sa vie
le canadien bombardier le l'espagnol
c'est le modèle un grand pis en pis on
dit venez chez nous la bienvenue et puis
ceux qui réussissent bravo coutu au
mieux mais là on a une espèce d'ambiance
qui consiste a dit attendez vous n'êtes
pas les bienvenus
parce qu'ils vont bien si si vous pouvez
vouloir et en plus ces murs n'aura
jamais le premier est un divorce accord
très grave et très profonde à coeur le
premier ministre y parle toujours de la
défense des entreprises aujourd'hui il
dit qu'il veut nous mettre le paquet sur
l'innovation si parle moins du coût du
travail
le gouvernement lance la banque publique
d'investissement un guichet unique pour
les entrepreneurs
c'est une bonne idée selon vous est ce
que c'est mais ses prises comique
mes amis je vous le dis ça fait partie
de la fausse bonne idée qui se baladent
quoi s'agit-il
il s'agit de prendre de trucs existent
pas 1 1 qui finance les l'actionnariat
et l'autre qui financent les entreprises
on va dire à faire un truc on va les
mélanger à génial les géniales conflits
d'intérêts totale prise d'otage complète
parce que pour réaliser un thé
lectionnaire mais vous êtes aussi
prêteurs donc ça et que ça va pas en
plus il y aura du chantage politique
c'est une erreur
il faut évidemment qui est d'un
financement long terme pour les android
en version via on dit maintenant il faut
avec mais ça ça existe déjà existants
y'a pas un n ya pas un euro de plus et
il ya un risque de confusion grave avec
le nouveau crédit lyonnais alors là
avant et oui forcément
la série de nouveaux crédits
un risque qu'il faut dire tout de suite
à l'auberge ont même pensé que c'était
le job d'un côté permet de vous que ce
choix
vous n'entrez choix jusqu'à présent
c'est une rumeur bien orchestré que je
sache je reviens sur le fond on peut pas
dire on sait par les banques d'affaires
et les banques de dépôt et dans ce
circuit là il ya déjà une banque
d'affairé déjà une banque de dépôt je
résume
et dire là on va fusionner c'est un
conflit d'intérêts majeurs auxquels
seront soumis les administrateurs de la
bp donc j'imagine qu'ils vont y
réfléchir je souhaite que jean pierre
jouyet tous ces gens qui sont absolument
remarquable face une position
intelligente mais pas de confusion juste
pour faire croire qu'on à honorer une
promesse de campagne ont mangé du lion
n'ont pas été touchés j'avais une angine
et je me suis marré pouilleux petites
questions rapides les propos son déficit
qui sont un objectif impératif a rappelé
le premier ministre est ce qu'il sera
tenu selon oui ou non j'en sais rien
parce que kabyles sont dans un cycle
complètement récifs et ils ont près
d'essayer de jouer l'austérité
l'austérité qui tu as commente en
récession françois fillon et the man zoo
arrêter les gens pas de l'austérité stay
on arrête les services à la personne qui
est quand même le premier set au
créateur d'emplois de france on arrête
ou quasiment réduit les crédits d'impôt
pour l'efficacité énergétique des
bâtiments réduits les éco prêts à taux
zéro il ya plus près d'un milliard de
chansons de la caisse des dépôts pour ça
on n'attend plus rien dans le sel nord
mais j'en sais rien il met en chantier
musée qui vous est cher et qu'il avait
vu qu'elle n'a plus de financement pour
ton copain de mon fils c'est là où le
bricolage devient quasi invraisemblable
vous savez par qui ces pied un projet
comme ça de 5 milliards qui va créer 40
50 mille emplois légistique enfance
aqcpe on avait parlé de leur entreprise
bric cdm l'europe pour lui demande plus
d'argent et monsieur gossio
oui vous allez voter c'est moi qui ai
signé bien sûr cette optique lortie qui
nous est très cher
non mais la france qui est très cher
c'est l'utilisateur qui payent la moitié
oui c'est les péniches qui pâtissent
financé par les péages des péniches
s'est fait comme ça
le reste c'est les régions le point est
financeurs qui me signer qui nous a
souligné
on est le cas une petite bille ces
voiliers de région et une mobilisation
de droite comme de
je les ai lus projet le grand palais 3 %
je vais vous dire il souhaite lancer une
politique de stricte austérité comptable
elle tourne le dos à la croissance donc
à quel moment ça c'est vrai se croiser à
quel moment passe à -2 0% dans six mois
dans un an dans deux ans là il ya un
vrai danger on reste ici je voulais vous
poser une question sur le mariage gay
qui étaient confirmés 1 vous le soir il
a été confirmé que des projets mini
stade il y aura l'adoption mariage des
personnes de même sexe mais il avouant à
la procréation médicalement assistée
est ce que vous voulez vous réclamez la
pma pour les couples gay ou pas coûter
prenons déjà ce qu'ils pensent à dakar à
moi je soutiens des remous nous sommes
pas unis à lui dit sur ce point mais
dans ce mot là c'est clair on n'y a pas
de débat moi j'y suis fabre alors
j'avais envie de vous dire que vous
aviez choisi d'être un opposant
constructif là vous êtes quand même très
offensif sur les autos vous avez beau et
les gens prêtent à venir la semaine
dernière un jour on a voté trois textes
quand même premiers 3 oui la vie chère
en outre-mer oui ils ont pesé à venir il
traitait de retraités vivant alors
l'opposition elle dit
l'ump dit elle être dans une opposition
beaucoup plus frontale en tant que les
cas particulièrement jean françois copé
vous ne vous prononcez pas jean louis
borloo sur cette compo compétition pour
la présidence de l'ump
mais le rival de françois fillon pousse
déjà vers vous semble-t-il certains élus
ump au sénat alors avant et oui vous
allez voir tout de suite avant
d'accueillir pierre quitter l'île de la
fp l'enquète de françois goulard sur
votre force d'attraction au centre alors
tu es devenu centriste c'est la nouvelle
blague qui circule dans les rangs des
sénateurs ump
plusieurs d'entre eux sont en
négociation avec lui dit le nouveau
parti de jean-louis borloo
et il menace si jean françois copé gagne
la présidence du parti
on part au centre la droitisation du
discours à l'ump déplaît au sein de ces
humanistes et les idées de l'ancien
ministre de l'écologie font mouche en
tant que centriste de l'ump je me sens
souvent très proches de positions prises
par jean louis borloo toute la question
c'est la capacité de l'ump à garder
cette diversité en son sein et à
permettre le débat la question est
ouverte
cette stratégie de débauchage l'udps et
il assume parfaitement
elle récolte simplement les fruits de la
guerre fillon copé je pense que nous
avons dimanche marge de progression
ce qu'il faut c'est démontrer que le
rassemblement est effectif il leur reste
à sortir de ce déchirement
s'ils viennent chez nous ils seront les
bienvenus d'autant que la voie est libre
au centre de l'échiquier politique
françois bayrou est plus seul que jamais
les cadres du modem ont rejoint
jean-louis borloo le leadership a changé
de mains je n'ai pas tourné casaque je
suis toujours membre du modem
ça peut paraître paradoxal en réalité
c'est la même famille je crois
qu'aujourd'hui jean louis borloo
rassemble on est tous autour de jean
louis borloo mais je pense que françois
bayrou à sa place de l'élection de
françois fillon ou de jean-françois copé
dépendra l'avenir de l'ue dit elle
révélera aussi si les sénateurs ump
rebelles n'ont pas tout simplement fait
un coup de bluff
et de jean louis borloo les questions
maintenant de pierre roques et de
l'agencé france-presse consorts pierre
bonsoir monsieur borloo bonsoir ça ben
je vais rebondir directement sur le
reportage qu'il convient de l'entendre
certains de vos amis
dro par exemple maurice leroy disent
qu'une victoire de jean françois copé de
l'ump ouvrirait un boulevard à lui dit
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
ça peut avoir une conséquence
enfin ça change strictement rien que ce
soit françois bugnion ou d'anciens
copains c'est l'électorat rpr de
poitiers classique génère voilà c'est ça
la réalité et ça c'est plutôt un peu
plus droitiser que par rapport à
l'époque du rhdp c'était différent que
c'est un impact sur telle ou telle
déroute au chalut rien
martineau mois ses proches de copé donc
tout ça c'est beaucoup plus il ya 10 et
d amitié personnelle je respecte
d'ailleurs que damon betty
la réalité c'est que les idées font pas
de l'ump la réalité c'est la survie du
mp va dépendre de lui c'est plutôt ça ce
qui va se passer mais pourquoi les
délices et l'une d'elles du 21e siècle
voilà c'est lui est fêtée être s'est
imposée très très vite en un an ou deux
comme la première force politique de ce
pays elle était la première force
territoriales nous allons naturellement
parce que les français et à une grande
partie des français qu'on a plein d'eau
qu'on se replie sur soi qu'on ait peur
de l'autre qu'on ait peur de l'europe en
épingle allemand qu'on ait peur de la
grave qu'on ait peur du noir
donc on est pendus bouazza voilà que ce
soit le voisin outre rhin où le voisin
outre scène et il ya une partie de la
france qui préfère se préparer aux
grands espaces que ses enfants voyagent
que les études fois passionnante qui est
de l'alternance qu'on vise haut et qu'on
soit généreux à la maison voilà ça elle
existe en français moi je vous dis c'est
la france en marche c'est la france qui
marchent tous les autres c'est la france
antilles mpm non c'est la france tout
court c'est la france que social
libérale européenne ouverte voilà on a
nous on accorde doctrinaux et les sommes
soient totalement européens ce qui ne
veut pas dire qu'on veuille pas changer
des choses dans le concert européen mais
pour plus d'intégration au contraire 20
voilà on a un corps de doctrine qui est
parfaitement clair
et nous sommes une force qui a vocation
à être la première de france ça va se
faire assez naturellement les
parlementaires du ils ont été élus dans
une autre période je veux dire on
n'existait pas et on va pas passer notre
temps à déboucher ce que veulent bien
devienne le seuil seront évidemment les
bienvenus mais c'est pas du tout propos
c'est pas le sujet nous nos prochaines
échéances c'est européenne d'abuser leur
part dieu que c'est vrai pour les
valeurs de l'ue des items que vous lui
avez l'écrit dia le respect de l'autre
il ya la tolérance le dialogue est ce
que vous n'êtes pas gêné quand vous
entendez jean françois copé justement
parler de racisme anti-blancs raconter
son histoire de pains au chocolat savent
ça vous met pas mal à l'aise même et il
ya des tas de choses qui me met mal à
l'aise à gauche vous savez prendre des
coalitions c'est que vous faites pas une
collection et des gens qui vous
ressemble voilà son problème des
collections c'est une compétition
coalition et vous aussi d'imposer vos
valeurs je pense pas car l'avoir insulté
la famille pour jour où ça soit très
bien d'expliquer aux français que la
france s est pas c'est pas fait pour ce
conte reprenne c'est pas très bien je
trouve qu'il ya une ambiance en ce
moment dans ce pays imposé par l'extrême
gauche le ps qui a une devrait l'acheter
je trouve pas ça bien être dans un
programme budgétaire
on commence par taper les ouvriers
français parce qu'on n'aime tellement
pas les entreprises que les heures
supplémentaires est bon on va aller
ramasser qui paye les 9 millions
d'ouvriers du public et du privé
voilà je trouve pas ça bien alors quand
même une question les alliances les
audiences elles sont forcément à droite
pour vous mais parce que la gauche
forcément l'extrême gauche nous côté là
c'est bien
vous avez vu comment ça se passe voilà
là le ps français a choisi son extrême
gauche que ce soit l'extrême gauche
déguisé en verre ou en fin ou habillés
en vert ou l'extrême gauche à billets
apc à une époque puis front de gauche
aujourd'hui puis demain je sais pas quoi
c'est son choix
voilà partir de ce moment là mais il n'y
a pas d'alliance avec l'extrême gauche
donc par capillarité les choses sont
assez simples
cela fait fixer une limite où vous dites
si je mets il ya des accords et on avait
loupé avec l'extrême droite
tabanou alors là on l'est on l'est on me
dira pas nous on n'a pas d'accord avec
avec l'extrême droite en a pas d'accord
excellent l'extrême gauche mal la
position à l'est de new york arte et on
verra je mâche imagine pas qu on est d
accord avec au front voilà je me
plongeais municipal s'est passé mais on
verra bien je ne vais pas commencer à
faire de la science fiction mosley il ya
une famille politique qui est dominant
dans ce pays c'est les gens qui ont
envie du dynamisme qui aiment ce pays
qui ne considère ouvert sur le monde qui
considère qui est l'intégration à marche
plutôt bien que quelle que soit sa
couleur par lee non mais génère-t-elle
bienvenus bon d'accord mais elle doit
être présentée elle sera dominante est
ce que vous estimez que le discours tenu
par jean françois copé qui sont des
c'est la dernière fois il était là la
semaine dernière mais je m'en fous pas
moi il était la chaîne la mère lui dit
il se défend et de l'udps il se défend
d'envisager tout accord avec un fonds
national non moi ma question pour vous
jean louis borloo c'est est ce que le
discours de jean françois copé est le
prélude à des accords entre l'ump et le
front national il a répondu non mais bon
qu'est ce que vous en dites moi je pense
plutôt que dont je pensais que non
d'accord mais il dort et se taper une
primaire dans sa vie il a été battu aux
législatives à cause du froid on fera
qu'avec l'argent très bien voilà je lui
dis alors puisque je crois maintenant
mais simplement j'avais règle 1 chez les
pères nous ont parlé par un quart bon
voilà on passe le temps à bord a laissé
voir lui dit dimanche vous allez réunir
l'ensemble de vos amis à la mutualité
pour une assemblée constituante vous en
êtes où il ya des chiffres qui circulent
on parle de 25 30 mille adhérents
plusieurs milliers d'élus c'est c'est
vrai cécile ces chiffres sans détour
votre grève comme on a essayé de faire
100 % internet
donc tout est d'accès direct c'est assez
simple je parvenais à dimanche après
midi après l'émission sur une télé là
c'est de la hausse on avait une
intrusion toutes les dix secondes
pendant cinq heures de suite
donc voilà je suis incapable de venir on
dansera dimanche mais c'est des chiffres
de cet ordre là que vous pouvez même
probable mais c'est franchement si
c'était ça ce serait pas un exploit non
mais je dis il faut se rendre compte que
que nous sommes l'edf du 21e siècle box
hôtel à la première formation à l'époque
sauf qu'elle développement durable qui
n'existent pas fac était pas une
prolongation politique majeur donc il ya
des différences mais sur sept
sur cet espace progressiste c'était la
formation de livres du roi des femmes de
l'ibg du droit de vote à 18 ans j'ai
l'air si nous sommes ça vous pour le 21e
siècle il est encore longue je vous
donnais quel délai pour être vraiment la
force numéro un aux européennes on sera
en tête l'objectif objecté ah oui je
serais trop vous avez fixé comme la
barre très haut vous dis non
dans le public on sait pas ce que c'est
parce que je pense que la france elle a
besoin de ça sert sinon réussit pas
qu'est ce qui va se passer
qu'est ce qui va se passer hélas pas
cette espèce trop que la très très à
droite je sais pas d'ailleurs si
l'offrons sera pas deux ans sur cet
espace là elles vont se diviser
puis juste un ps qui aura toujours
l'extrême gauche non nous sommes
indispensables au pays pour ça que je me
battrai mois pour que cette formation
qu'est ce qui vous fait penser que vous
allez réussir là où vous depuis trente
ans et c'est chez ses pairs comme sa
dépendance était la première sanction
est auto détruite
oui intermède sais c'est pas que c'est
un échec c'est que c'est la plus grande
destruction de force politique
trois romans de l'histoire en tout cas
de l'histoire contemporaine l'état natif
de rassemblement
rien n'y a pas eu tant t il que des
tentatives de division qui est
totalement réussi
je vous remercie et avec avec l'arrêt
c'était un total silence la grèce est la
préfiguration de ce que c'est
aujourd'hui des plus ni moi et je vous
ai toujours dit que contrairement à
toutes les idées reçues c'est pas une
présidentielle complète une famille
politique c'est même plutôt sa mort à
peu prêt garanti c'est après les
législatives
je voulais écrire j'ai envoyé une
dépêche afp le 2 octobre à 20h une
jalousie mais c'est quand même 20 tours
2 je vous ai donné rendez vous aux
législatives jeudi qu'un groupe aux
législatives et qu'on va tirer cette
famille et on va d'ailleurs très au delà
de cette famille et j'en suis arrivé
dans ce cas là on a envie de vous parler
maintenant de s'arrêter après coop et de
suisse avait récemment un sondage ifop
qui pour les français mais roux reste le
look qui représente le centrisme
l'office qu'on peut faire un
rassemblement sans lui mais maintenant
c'est qu'est ce que ça veut dire mais
vous rendez compte que vous êtes en
train de dire des limites non mais des
milliers de maires de conseillers
régionaux des français qui s'engage et
vous dites est à un type parce que vous
le connaissez vous parce que vous savez
dix ans ça fait dix ans qu'ils vous
expliquez vous dire après l'élection
avec qui il va travailler et vous avez
trouvé ça formidable
moi je constate que c était une
destruction de famille c'est tout non
pas en plus un ami donc j'ai pas de
prendre personnel du tout simplement
vous n'apprenez pas mais qui viennent et
la pratique c'est dire avec qui on va
travailler sur quel projet sur quel
programme
l'idée que je vous dirai après c'est pas
une idée pertinente la preuve
c'était une destruction voilà quand il
vous dit on va travaux peut travailler
ensemble sans se renier
vous voulez pas vous voulez pas que oui
mais sur les européennes par exemple non
mais tu en es on peut faire des choses
ensemble toute la course j'ai revu mes
mais ça veut dire quoi à n'importe quel
âge seriez vous la question est ce qu'il
ya une est-ce que c'est complètement
bloquée ou skis et les ouvertures
possibles
notre avec reuters
vous savez quand c'est pas moins de
personnel on peut aller boue est
simplement nous on a on sait que dans
les grands pays que vous défendez vos
idées vous foot coalition vous pouvez
pas dire aux gens
ma coalition je tends parlerai après
donc c'est une différence fondamentale
et assumé chaque position et respectable
l'a noté il ya une différence entre vous
et françois bayrou qui s'est lui s'en
veut toujours très attaché à son destin
présidentiel
il a même proposé une primaire en 2017
c'est une idée ça la présidentielle pour
monsieur décide 2017
il s'en sera passé tellement de choses
techniques que c'est m6 qui fera les
sélections régionales voilà non mais je
plaisante mais il va se passer tellement
de choses tellement bouleversement
croyez pas qu'on peut s'occuper les
professions poulpe et paul et du putsch
ou mal un plan de cohésion sociale
je ne courrai pas que c'est autrement
plus important quelle europe on veut
est-ce qu'on veut nous un gouvernement
économique là elle madame merkel a parlé
à la france ça fait un mois lui a
toujours pas répondu moi je ne fais une
lettre après demain puisque le
gouvernement répond pas aux propositions
de la chancelière sur l'europe
je vais me répondre comme je l'avais
fait en août 2011 mais sur le fond est
ce que vous pensez que la vocation d'un
parti c'est obligatoirement d'avoir un
candidat à la présidence est longue
c'est un élément voilà à une époque
l'obligatoire et le rpr on avait bien ne
jetant des élus fo n'avait pas demain
qu'est ce que c'est pas du tout le sujet
une force peu tout ou pis la prison c
est la fin d'un processus qui a commencé
par les cantons par les communes par les
départements parlée par les régions
voilà
mais c'est pas un truc à festival de
cannes en apesanteur j'ai perdu mon du
seul sur la droite la droite droite
comme il fallait il va inviter une
émission j'avais aujourd'hui la droite
forte qui est incarnée par les jeunes
pousses de l'ump veut interdire
carrément le droit de grève aux
enseignants c'est une passion du ham
venez pas me demander de commenter tous
envie de réagir et agir armée fallait
dire vous m'invitez une réunion sur la
droite française on voulait passer
consultation mais dans ce genre et
tendre
vous parlez ce que fait le gouvernement
de la france on nous l'avait trailer
vous avec ce qu'ils devraient faire
qu'est ce que nos positions
constructives et quand même comment on
prépare les européennes relatives à sa
vous allez en parler longuement dimanche
et d'ailleurs ce sera à suivre sur les
chaînes parlementaires tout au long de
la matinée pour votre assemblée
constitutive premier nicolas sarkozy au
fort avec bienveillance et vous lui
demanderez
qu'est ce que vous a dit de l'événement
et vous allez vous lui demanderez savez
en avant le gouvernement je n'ai jamais
donné une info nidda conseiller mini
d'une conversation poser nue comme d'une
conversation entre e minute une corsa
sans être prévenu président jammeh je
vais pas commencer maintenant cho-power
de guerre qu'est ce que vous répondez
quelques sceptiques de votre quand il y
en a qui peuvent ce qui se disait ce que
jean louis borloo ira jusqu'au bout et
ce qui va pas nous lâcher un moment
donné en rase campagne serait souvent se
référant au fait que vous n'avez pas été
au bout de la présidentielle qui avait
raison sur la présidentielle qui avait
raison non mais attendez qu'ils avaient
raison répondez à la question ci non
mais attendez mon père attendant le
faire non plus de ce monsieur mais vous
êtes gentils vous n'échapperez pas à
l'acte de contrition qui considère qu'un
type cas pas de prime de signature fait
10% doit évidemment y aller sans aucune
réflexion politique pour marquer des
gens en sachant que ça permet pas de
gagner ça n'a pas d'importance tout ça
bon que ça d'être une famille petite
sarah mais nous nous les journées ce
petit que ça nous fait mal alors croyez
un type qui décide pas je vais pas faire
le spectacle
là ça c'est pas bien d'après ces
résultats qu'à nos amis vous avez 6 aces
à 2 tu as une petite dose reçue une à
dire que c'est ta femme qui a pas voulu
nommer tôt vous êtes quand même barjots
vous avez un an après la preuve que
l'analyse politique était juste que ceux
qui sont allés se sont tous plantés
qu'on détruit leur faim grosses banques
certains avaient mis des bretelles avant
avec madoff
en effet alors je dois dire mais je veux
aller où tu as j'ai dit une chose parce
que je me suis levé de valenciennes je
les fais quand j'ai fait mini j'ai fait
ministre à fond quand j'ai fait avocat
j'ai fait avocats font quand j'ai fait
industrie jeffers du sénat fond quand je
fais lui dit je ferai du livre on s'est
dit alors vous avez déçus de personnes
présentes au palais présidentiel alors
atteint rama yade cette équipe 2e je
sais pas bien tu as donné son mari merci
des rocky kelly perrine tarneaud de
public sénat va nous rejoindre ton pire
juste avant et ça va être encore pire
maintenant avec cette enquête de jérôme
rabih kayrouz autre centre d'intérêt
jean louis borloo ce qui nous amène
certaines activités passées car la
politique pour vous n'est pas tout quand
même c'est sur les bancs du lycée janson
de sailly où il côtoie notamment vincent
bolloré que jean louis borloo construit
son premier clan son premier réseau est
très vite son style détone pas du tout
le typique premier de classe mais un
type doué d'une facilité assez
incroyable c'était déjà le type qui
démarrait plus vite que les autres et
qui est arrivé là où on l'attendait pas
c'est en montant un cabinet d'avocats en
77 il fait fortune
sa spécialité les faillites et
restructurations d'entreprises leucate
brunel à deux pas de la place de
l'étoile devient le lieu à fréquenter
pour les investisseurs bernard tapie
bien sûr mais aussi michel cuenca sous
vincent bolloré qu'il retrouve son
réseau d'affaires est né les raisons se
les est constitué on a trouvé les chefs
d'entreprises dont bernard était
l'anglais qui ont été mises en valeur et
on s'est dit alors c'est les années fric
alors bernard est un bateau avant
l'avion entre le hockey et nous
l'attendons les avocats d'affaires on a
pris un peu à peu ces poussières qui
retombait en dix ans les golden boys
jean louis borloo qui prend des petites
participations dans ces entreprises est
alors classé par le magazine forbes dans
le top 5 des avocats d'affaires les
mieux payés au monde plus habitué aux
soirées parisiennes ou tropézienne qu'à
valenciennes mais une rencontre change
tout alors qu'il écume les tribunaux de
commerce pour ses affaires on lui parle
du club de foot de valenciennes rond
liquidation
j'ai lu mais qu'est ce que tu as fait
aimer débat j'ai déposé le bilan du club
j'en ai monté un nouveau et je n'y mets
tu as trouvé les gens pour le faire mais
ils n'ont pas encore donc j'ai pris la
présidence et puis on verra bien mais on
pouvait pas laisser tomber ce truc là le
foot pour commencer puis nouveau
tournant quand la ville menace de couper
les subventions du club
je suis dit mais qu'est ce que tu vas
faire il m'a dit je sais pas et puis il
m'a regardé en sourire et m'a dit on va
leur pic et l'amérique et il l'a fait
il aurait très bien pu continuer à être
avocat c'est est d'ailleurs le l'avim
qui la reprise et est d'abord une
entreprise en difficulté sa nouvelle vie
consacrée à la politique est lancé même
si ses relations privilégiées avec le
monde des affaires ne sont jamais loin
dernière occasion janvier quand son ami
celui qu'il appelle son frère henri
proglio pdg d'edf tente de l'imposer à
la tête de veolia environnement
mais le timing en pleine campagne
présidentielle les fait reculer sans
doute sa dernière opportunité de revenir
dans les affaires à 61 ans je pas sûr
que gagner de l'argent même si ça peut
être l'indépendance soit un truc qui le
passionne ce qui est sûr c'est que ce
qu'il est en train de faire maintenant
ça le passionne
et quand il est passionné il est jamais
aussi bon qu'à ce moment là c'est vrai
que vous êtes passionné un peu le but de
cette émission pour votre nouveau projet
politique et jean louis borloo et
perrine tarneaud nous rejoindre soit
repéré mon sens il va parvenir savent
pas s'ils font de l'idée on en a
largement discuté tout à l'heure on a
compris moi j'ai discuté aujourd'hui
avec pierre charon qui lui dit que vous
êtes chauds comme la braise pour venir à
paris et prendre la mairie de paris sur
seront sénateur ump de paris la question
ont confirmé leur peau de pierre charon
halte au chocolat chaud comme la braise
en ce moment ça je vous rassure on avait
vu ça il ya aucun problème que vous
pouvez les de vous présenter à paris si
vous expliquez ça va être comme pour la
présidentielle il va falloir vous
mettiez tête que la politique c'est pas
du spectacle mais ça n'est pas du sperme
et laissez-moi terminé lui
il sait ce qui va sauver notre pays non
mais je suis très sérieux
je pense que cette france généreuse et
ouverte elle existe elle est
indispensable à la saison et ça va
attendait ça va mal se terminer
et donc dans tout ça j'ai ma stabilité
voilà j'ai dit ok les gars je m'en
occupe d'ici là les sénateurs lahoud
huillet et jean louis martinelli nom et
yann aurions à les municipales à
toulouse a qu à angers à paris et on
bâtira des listes mais est ce que moi
j'ai la capacité attendait mais je
regrette simplement
et une fois de plus pour une fois vous
allez pas commenter ce que je dis est
relié ce que je dis ou alors faut
changer de métier je ne sais pas si je
peux distraire suffisamment de temps de
lui dit pour ça j'en aurai une intuition
une conviction dans deux mois trois mois
va là parce que lui dit c'est très
important
il s'agit pas de l'aventuré d'un homme à
paris il s'agit d'un mouvement politique
globale je pense effectivement que paris
honnêtement est resté sur son
périphérique ballack il faut une
communauté urbaine
je crois que bon c'était sleeping beauty
bromont c'est pas mal la plage des trucs
tout ça mais enfin bon on peut
franchement faire faire mieux n'éluder
est prioritaire pour moi voilà est-ce
que j'ai noté qu'il y met à la droite et
pour le sang alors donc le second
n'essaie pas de retraite des uns ou des
autres la question c'est non mais non
mais non non ce qui est là où vous avez
raison c'est qu'il ya des priorités dans
une ville il ya des brides ces deux ou
trois mandats
le voilà il ya ainsi qu en plus il était
un peu c'est un peu charmant qu'au début
les plages les nuits blanches ou saab on
n'a rien fait d'autre j'ai entendu j'ai
pas dit ça je peux entrer dans cette
polémique mais c'est pas mon propos mais
aujourd'hui lui dites prioritaires
paris c'est une un des objectifs clairs
que nous avons a comme tout le grand
ouest comme tout le sud-ouest la crise
là c'est clair parce que parce que c'est
pas l'ump qui va pouvoir gagner bâle
tente on aura terminé nos travaux c'est
à dire dans deux mois je vous dirais
qu'elles sont l'egypte par exemple ses
tableaux il me suis occupé beaucoup de
rouen sur trois ans nous aurons une
équipe que je crois formidable je pense
emmené par une femme de très grande
qualité
et puis je pense qu'on va gagner ou en
voilà mais j'aurai l'occasion d'en
reparler
il fallut attendre et aidera aussi des
ambitions à paris françois fillon
ben j'sais pas j'ai pas le sentiment je
crois qu'il avait dit ça pour venir dans
le 7e bon et maintenant qu'il est dans
le septième jeu ne sais pas ce qui est
décédera vous avez un sens qu'il a déjà
abandonné la mairie de paris vous
l'inviterai l'attend mais en tout cas
les élus ump sont nombreux à paris à
vouloir se ranger derrière vous est ce
que ça veut dire qu'il se cherche un
leader ça veut simplement dire que le
délit est très important dans le pays
parce que ce que vous dites est vrai
dans la moitié du territoire les deux
tiers du territoire national à peu près
partout
on a besoin que ce soit ludique qui
tirent les listes voilà où qui
renouvelle dans une compétition
éventuels ex ump
les européennes tout le monde a bien
compris qui elle serait en tête aux
européennes c'est évidemment nous
l'exemple de paris les illustrations que
le bocal des commentaires taccoen
parlementaire n'a pas de sens qu'en
réalité la force qui va qui est à la
fois moderne européenne écologiste
fraternelle qui concerne la diversité
des races et des cultures est une
richesse dans ce même lycée qui va eh
bien voyez il ya tellement de choses à
faire tellement de choses à faire
tellement que ça mérite qu'on s'y
consacre à fond l'assassinât aujourd'hui
encore ceux d'un avocat antoine
sollacaro c'est une première en corse
depuis plus de vingt ans vous le
connaissiez oui je le connais je
connaissais noël dire au delà du
problème personnel qui me fait beaucoup
de peine
faut bien se rend compte de ce que veut
dire la mort d'un avocat si c'est parce
qu'il est avocat
deux hommes à moto le port de la robe
madame c'est une armure c'est une armure
qui permet à un homme de ne plus exister
pour n'être plus que la défense des
autres vous vous effacez d'arrêt votre
robe pour n'existait pas vous n'avez pas
de que si vous n'êtes pas de chaussures
avait pas de cas vous n'avez pas de
cavale d'un mais c'est vrai que je vous
dise si c'est ce que j'ai vaguement
entendu mais joli niort ça c'est d'une
gravité extrême et je suis très triste
pour la corse c'est avec ma maman et une
à quoi vivre
c'est un peu mon pays je suis très très
belle valse a dit à propos effectivement
de la mort de celui qui fut l'avocat de
l'un d'eux la servante que le préfet
rien que c'était une atteinte à l'état
de droit
presque plus que ça parce qu'il ya des
avocats dans des états qui ne sont pas
des états de droit et il devrait au
cours plus protégés dans des états qui
ne sont pas des états donneront faut que
c'est très très grave
une question avec notre partenaire
orange et leur application tivi tchèque
c'est une question de simon est ce que
le projet de loi 2013 pénalise les clubs
de foot français au faux pas plus que
les autres entreprises françaises quand
je veux dire c'est sa vie et sa vie
essentiellement des droits télé 1les
foot le foot et du mercato des joueurs
donc oui mais on va franchement ce pas
c'est pas ça qui m'ennuie le plus
franchement
ouais mais jean michel aulas par exemple
a dit que le foot français ne sera plus
compétitive que les meilleurs joueurs
allaient partir à l'étranger vous n'avez
pas les mêmes partis j'ai pas les mêmes
6 mai enfin oui sauf qu'il ya tellement
bien ça s'est passé ainsi moi je pense
qu'on sait grouillera sega il ya des
secteurs d'activité qui me préoccupe
toutes les nouvelles technologies tout
la biotechnique le fait de voir et ça je
le vois je suis navré c'est pas dans la
presse mais que des groupes mondiaux
installés ici discrètement parce que
parce que parce que ça commence à
organiser le transfert de leurs
meilleurs cadres des services de
recherche des services de marketing les
services financiers de services
logistiques dans d'autres pays et pas
seulement pour des raisons de poids
fiscal oui ap mais parce que l'ambiance
est pas bonne
fondée par contre qu'est le divorce qui
sait en quatre mois
l'alternance à devrait être la joie ça
devrait que l'euphorie
même pour ceux qui ont pas voté pour ce
qu'ils sont a balayé mon vélo j'étais
pas participer vous mais n'ont même pas
pensé à leforest non mais je veux dire
là il ya un nouveau gouvernement c'est
bon c'est pas vrai c'est pas la question
sur vous pour finir jean pierre raffarin
dit que vous êtes branché sur courant
alternatif
vous vous reconnaissez dans ce portrait
je suppose que ça va et plus ça
m'étonnerait que la phrase il a aussi
dit que j'avais été son ministre le plus
pénible quand ils défendent est
notamment la rénovation urbaine mais le
plus loin et plus bosseur il a même dit
devant les sénateurs à jour ici que ce
dont il avait été le plus fier dans sa
vie le premier ministre c'est d'avoir
été le premier ministe du plan de
rénovation urbaine de 40 milliards des
banques qui avaient changé la vie de
quatre millions de personnes
mais il avait ajouté c'est rare qu'en
politique on ait le temps de voir une
telle se réaliser je me souviens que
dans les derniers temps du quinquennat
de nicolas sarkozy vous aviez tess aussi
au dernier sommet social avec notamment
avait-on dit bonjour te ment pas
directement mais gérard larcher lui des
contacts à la trêve et tvo à la cgt
avait-on dit qu'est ce que vous pensez
de la succession de bernard thibault qui
a choisi un inconnu là monsieur le paon
et belge
par nature le centralisme démocratique a
sûrement fait le bon choix
par définition voilà et donc voilà je
souhaite mais il savait les sujets du
paritarisme et de la cgt marita oui mais
ce qui est important et un tiers des
flux considérable dans notre pays fait
qu'on doit regarder ce sujet syndicales
et sa faiblesse comme un des grands
sujets du 21e siècle
merci beaucoup jean louis borloo on dit
que vous avez un moteur diesel dont vous
aviez un mot de moteurs de formule 1 ce
soir à ça vous donne la perspective donc
de cette assemblée constituante de lui
dit que nous suivrons en direct sur les
chaînes parlementaires dimanche à partir
de 10h45 on vous retrouvera ce moment là
merci à la semaine prochaine
le vrai courage gilles leclair s'est pas
d'augmenter les impôts tout le monde
sait le faire nicolas sarkozy est parti
mais la crise est pas parti la politique
économique du gouvernement
je lui donnerai un zéro pointé tous les
matins à 8 heures 15
guillaume durand et jean leclerc
reçoivent une personnalité politique
dans l'invité politique reconçu à sa
crédibilité
reconstruire sa popularité il faut pas
préjuger on peut juger après en
partenariat avec radio classique
l'invité politique
tous les matins à 8h 15 en direct sur
public sénat
chaque année au sénat le concours
talents des cités récompense de jeunes
créateurs d'entreprises issus des
quartiers depuis dix ans chaque remise
de prix est l'occasion de rappeler leur
parcours exemplaire et les obstacles
qu'ils ont dû surmonter je vais réussir
j'ai prouvé que je peux réussir je vais
tellement le dire que tous ceux qui
voudront faire comme moi ils se diront
s'il a pu le faire non pourra le faire
le documentaire talents des cités
que sont ils devenus est parti à la
rencontre de plusieurs lauréats pour que
leur aventure
puissant et inspiré d'autres et que tous
les talents puisse s'exprimer
talents des cités que sont ils devenus
samedi à 22 heures sur public sénat sa
démarche est assurée et pourtant
à 28 ans clarisse n'a plus l'insouciance
des jeunes femmes de son âge photographe
elle s'est investie en 2010 dans l'un
des 110 cas de son entreprise
très vite elle accède à des
responsabilités importantes
une ascension fulgurante mais clarisse
au quotidien subi le comportement
déplacé du dirigeant de la section
syndicale
ça commence par des petites flatterie
tard un très joli regard tu as très
beaux yeux ça passe ensuite par q passe
pas inaperçu quand tu rentres quelque
part on ne peut que se souvenir de toi
et puis après ça passe par des
il va falloir qu'on se téléphone tous
les soirs que j'étais au téléphone tous
les jours pour faire des rapports ça
passe ensuite par il va falloir qu'on se
voit tes des sms à caractère sexuel avec
des chichas la fin et puis ça a été
quand on est parti en congrès syndical
ça a été un tapage de portes à à 23h30
avec en peignoir et est plutôt pas
habillé dessous avec je m'allonge sur le
lit à côté et je te demande de coucher
avec moi
acculé clarisse se décide à en parler à
sa hiérarchie à son entourage
mais le mal est fait maintenant je suis
incapable de me retrouver devant un
homme sans me dire est-ce que j'ai une
attitude qui provoque ou pas je me
demandais ce que je donne maquiller est
ce que je dois me coiffer ou est ce que
je devrais comment est ce que je peux
mettre des talons
est ce que mon pantalon et pas trop
serré j'ose même pas sourire à quelqu'un
ou alors dès qu'on rentre dans un
sourire j'essaye de casser ça tout de
suite parce que je me dis je veux plus
qu'il m'arrive ça ça le harcèlement
sexuel un délit jusqu'ici reconnu et
sanctionné dans le code pénal mais le 4
mai dernier le conseil constitutionnel à
broche purement et simplement la loi sur
le harcèlement sexuel
le harcèlement sexuel rayé du cocb
aimable texte est jugée trop floue les
associations et les féministes dénoncent
là un vide juridique
c'est un coup de tonnerre et c'est la
conséquence d'une nouvelle qpc comme
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité les féministes parler
une catastrophe car toutes les
procédures en cours sont de fait annulée
conséquence de la censure en effet des
centaines de procédures sont classés en
raison d'un obstacle juridique le
harceleur de clarisse comme beaucoup
d'autres ne pourra jamais être poursuivi
le harcèlement sexuel en france devient
par défaut non sanctionné et moi du
monde politique
tollé du côté des associations il y a
urgence pour combler le vide juridique
il faut rédiger une nouvelle loi en
pleine campagne législative
les députés ne siègent plus le sénat
s'empare du sujet en quelques jours un
groupe de travail commun à la commission
des lois des affaires sociales et à la
délégation aux droits des femmes est
constitué le 23 mai 2012 au travers de
la vingtaine de sénateurs qui
participent tous les groupes politiques
sont représentés le conseil
constitutionnel a considéré que la
formulation actuelle n'était pas assez
précise c'est à dire que le harcèlement
des et sexuelle n'est pas défini dont il
nous semble qu'il faut trouver ni nous
apparaît à l'évidence que pour répondre
à ce qu'a dit le conseil constitutionnel
qui s'impose à nous comme aux pouvoirs
exécutifs d'ailleurs il est nécessaire
d'arriver à une formulation plus clair
il faut essayer d'harmoniser la
définition les définitions européenne et
les faire coïncider avec le droit
français
plusieurs lois sont intervenus qui ont
quelque sorte ont un peu d'être écarté
la législation ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui nous arrivons à une
abrogation
pour les sénateurs il va falloir rédigé
la qualification du délit
on commence et où finit le harcèlement
sexuel
ce n'est pas simple de définir le moment
où il ne s'agit pas d'une séduction
légitime et le moment où c'est un
harcèlement contraire au gré à la
volonté de la personne qui est harcelé
question de sémantique chaque mot doit
être pensée repenser analysé
françois molins qui est procureur de la
république près les tribunaux de grande
instance de paris
et pour alimenter leur réflexion les
sénateurs rencontre magistrats avocats
et associations
ça avance je trouve franchement on
apprécie chez toi qui va nous tomber sur
la tête
le gouvernement prend de court les
parlementaires et annonce un projet de
loi porté par la garde des sceaux et la
ministre à l'égalité